Was, dann kommen wir noch
zu einem speziellen Art, also Tupel.
Tupels sind sehr ähnlich zu Listen,
nur können wir sie nicht verändern.
Das heißt,
das hat man davor auch schon kurz gesehen,
wenn ich dann nochmal
zum Coating gehe,
hier das hier,
ist ein Tupel,
das kann ich nicht mehr verändern,
und das hat halt
ein paar Vorteile,
also es ist einerseits,
hat es praktisch das ganze
drum herum bei den Listen nicht,
das heißt,
wenn ich dieses Tupel mal definiert habe,
dann ist es konstant,
das braucht viel weniger Speicher,
und das hat eben
verschiedene Verwendungsartwecke,
zum einen
habe ich zum Beispiel eben,
wenn wir später dann
Funktionen definieren,
ich mach das mal ganz kurz,
dann kann ich da
eben ein Tupel
zurückgeben,
und das kann ich eben so machen,
und generell ist ein Tupel,
also wenn ich ein Tupel definiere
als Variable,
ist das mit den runden Klammern.
Ich kann natürlich auf diese Werte zugreifen,
zum Beispiel, wenn ich hier
ein 1 reinschreib,
dann kann ich da wie
genauso wie bei Listen
mit der Indizierung
praktisch darauf zugreifen,
und ja,
es gibt da auch natürlich
wieder, kann wieder die Länge
herausfinden, mit dem Längenparameter,
generell sind den Tupel
praktisch werden verwendet,
um fixer
Sequenzen, fixer Rückgabewerte
zu definieren,
hat seine Vor- und Nachteile
zu den Listen, also da ist
nichts mehr veränderbar,
und das ist halt
ein Vergleich zu Tupel,
also zu Listen
sein Nachteil.
Genau, zum Beispiel
definiert man das eben so,
und das ist
dann so fast schon so eine Art
Konstant, das heißt praktisch
ich kann immer wieder auf dieses
Base-Color-Tupel da
hingehen und weiß,
okay, diese Werte hier sind nicht
verändert,
und
das sind praktisch so Fixpunkte
in meinem Code.